- Mein Name ist Matthias Wentland.
Ich bin Geschäftsführer im
Pflegeteam Wentland.
- Mein Name ist Patrycja Dalecka.
Ich bin im zweiten Ausbildungsjahr
als Altenpflegerin.
Seit zwei Jahren bin ich
im ambulanten Pflegedienst.
- Mein Name ist Rachid Afarsiou.
Ich bin Krankenpfleger,
arbeite für einen ambulanten Pflegedienst,
der circa 105 Patienten versorgt aktuell.
Genau, ich bin mit dem Auto
unterwegs zu den Patienten,
wo ich zu denen nach Hause fahre
und die dort versorge vor Ort.
- In der mobilen Pflege
fahren die Krankenpfleger zu
den Patienten nach Hause.
Ein wichtiger Aufgabenbereich:
die Grundpflege.
Hier geht es um die
Grundversorgung des Patienten:
Der Krankenpfleger wäscht und pflegt ihn.
Er muss viel mit dem Patienten sprechen.
Außerdem gibt es weitere
wichtige Aufgaben,
wie den Blutzucker zu messen ...
oder Verbände zu wechseln.
Alle Tätigkeiten, die man bei
jedem Patienten erledigt hat,
müssen dokumentiert werden.
Auch ein Gespräch mit den
Angehörigen kann dazugehören.
Mehr über den Beruf des Krankenpflegers
erfahrt ihr im nächsten Teil.
- Wir würden heute bei
Herrn Hombach starten.
Dort machen wir eine kleine Pflege
mit Lagern und Betten.
- Alles klar.
- Genau, dann würden wir
den Blutzucker messen
und entsprechend das Insulin spritzen
und dann nochmal die Medikamente
kontrollieren und die ihm verabreichen.
Genau, als Nächstes würden wir
dann zu der nächsten Patientin gehen,
die hat eine infizierte Bisswunde.
- Ach so, okay.
- Genau, die ist von einem Hund
gebissen worden.
Die Wunde hat sich infiziert, ist soweit
von einem Chirurgen versorgt worden
und soll jetzt durch den Pflegedienst,
quasi durch uns, versorgt werden,
bis sie dann abgeheilt ist.
- Okay, das sind zwei.
- Genau, richtig.
Wir würden am Anfang gucken,
dass wir das Übergabebuch lesen,
was die Kollegen eingetragen haben.
Gibt es irgendwelche Informationen,
hat jemand einen Arzttermin
oder irgendwas?
Genau, dann würden wir
die Schlüssel nehmen,
damit wir dann auch
in die Wohnung kommen.
Dann wäre ich soweit bereit.
Hast du noch Fragen?
- Bis jetzt nicht.
- Okay.
Wir würden uns die zwei Schlüssel von
unseren Patienten jetzt erst mal mitnehmen:
Das wäre einmal der Herr Hombach ...
und dann die andere
Patientin noch, ja?
Das sind die zwei Schlüssel,
die wir dann brauchen.
- Ja, alles klar.
Da haben wir die Medikamente.
Genau, die nehmen wir uns mit.
- Guten Morgen, Herr Afarsiou,
ich grüße Sie.
- Guten Morgen, Hallo Frau Hombach,
Ich hab heute eine Auszubildende dabei.
Das ist die Patrycja.
- Guten Morgen.
- Morgen, Petra Hombach.
Grüße Sie, kommen Sie rein.
- Danke.
- Ja, der Papa wartet schon sehnlichst.
- Guten Morgen.
Na, gut geschlafen?
- Sieht man doch.
- Ja.
Ich habe heute die Patrycja dabei,
das ist die neue Auszubildende.
- Guten Morgen.
Ich heiße Patrycja.
Herr Hombach, wir würden uns
gerade mal vorbereiten,
und dann würden wir zu Ihnen kommen
und uns um Sie kümmern, ja?
Dann fangen wir direkt mal damit an,
die Beine zu waschen. Okay?
- Ja, okay.
- Gut, das ist die Patientenakte.
Hier vorne hast du immer das Stammblatt,
dann kannst du einfach
die Stammdaten sehen,
dann hast du die Diagnosen,
die ja für uns relevant sind.
Er hat zum Beispiel jetzt hier Diabetes
Mellitus, der insulinpflichtig ist,
und das müssen wir
immer beachten nachher.
Du hast hier einmal die Leistungskarte,
da kannst du sehen,
was wir genau machen.
Heute haben wir den 14., da sind wir
mit der kleinen Pflege dran,
deswegen machen wir
die Beine im Bett, ne?
Genau. Hier hast du
dann den Pflegebericht,
damit du dann noch mal gucken kannst,
ob irgendwas Besonderes war.
Genau. Dann desinfizieren
wir uns einmal die Hände.
Dann gehen wir das
einmal zusammen durch.
So, die Patrycja wird jetzt
einmal die Beine waschen, ja?
Ich werde da ein bisschen
drauf gucken, ne?
Und schauen, ob alles so
weit okay ist, ne?
Und ob wir was verbessern können.
Ja?
- Herr Hombach, möchten Sie
Seife im Wasser haben?
- Bitte?
- Möchten Sie Seife im Wasser haben?
- Ja.
- Okay, das steht schon
alles da vorne bereit.
Einen guten Schuss! Genau!
Das reicht schon völlig aus.
Wichtig ist, den Schritt immer
dem Patienten zu erklären, ne?
Genau, was du eigentlich tust,
dass du das rechte Bein anhebst,
damit er sich nicht erschreckt
und ... genau.
- Ich hebe jetzt erst mal Ihr rechtes
Bein und ich fange mit dem Waschen an.
- Genau, wichtig ist immer:
Gegen die Haarrichtung gerade morgens,
weil wir damit den Patienten aktivieren.
Abends würden wir zum Beispiel
mit der Haarrichtung waschen, ja?
Ja, wir würden als Nächstes
die Blutzuckermessung machen,
um zu gucken, wie der Blutzucker ist,
und entsprechend sein Insulin spritzen,
damit er dann frühstücken kann.
Herr Hombach, ich würde gern einmal
den Blutzucker bei Ihnen messen, ja?
Da dürfen Sie mir einmal
eine Hand zur Verfügung stellen.
Genau, dann nehmen wir uns den hier.
Du hast hier einmal den Blutzuckerstick.
Du würdest hier einmal quasi ziehen,
bis es einrastet.
Dann hast du hier den Punkt,
wo du draufdrücken kannst,
und dann springt eine Nadel raus.
Dann nimmst du den ersten Tropfen
weg, das ist immer ganz wichtig.
Und dann hast du hier das Gerät,
wo du das Blut aufträgst.
Du siehst hier die Markierung,
hier kommt der Tropfen Blut drauf
– zack – und dann rechnet das Gerät
dir quasi den Blutzuckergehalt aus.
Wir haben jetzt 160,
das ist völlig in Ordnung.
Und dann würden wir nachher
das Insulin entsprechend [verabreichen].
So, Herr Hombach,
160 ist der Blutzucker,
das ist in Ordnung.
- Ja ja, das weiß ich.
Dann gucken wir gleich mal wegen
dem Insulin, wie viel Sie dann kriegen, ja?
Gut.
- So, jetzt sind wir fertig
mit dem Patienten.
Dann haben wir dann noch die
Dokumentation. Ganz wichtig.
- Das ist seine Mappe?
- Genau, richtig.
Wir haben unter drei
haben wir die Leistungskarte,
die ist ganz wichtig, weil die rechnen wir
nachher mit der Krankenkasse
und der Pflegekasse ab.
Genau,du siehst hier die Leistungen,
die sind schon geplant.
Genau, wir würden uns dann hier
quasi einfach nur eintragen
mit Uhrzeit und Handzeichen, dass wir
diese Leistung erbracht haben. Ja?
Und du siehst, hier steht wirklich
jede Leistung drinne,
die wir auch erbringen.
- Alles, was wir beobachten,
sollen wir hier [auf]schreiben.
- Genau, alles was so außergewöhnlich ist.
Wenn der Patient sagt,
er fühlt sich wohl, alles ist gut,
dann muss das hier gar nicht
drinne stehen, weil davon gehen wir aus …
Wir haben heute Morgen den
Herrn Hombach, Ihren Vater, versorgt.
Der ist super motiviert, hilft mit.
Man muss zwischendurch
immer Impulse setzen,
weil er das dann auch kognitiv nicht
umgesetzt kriegt, aber ansonsten …
- Ja, das ist das Schwierigste
für uns eigentlich, ja.
Sie machen das auch immer prima,
seit Sie da sind. Das ist wirklich toll.
Also, wir haben da manchmal
solche Probleme,
aber das ist wirklich eine super Hilfe.
- Sehr gut, das freut uns doch zu hören.
So, Frau Hombach, wir sehen uns morgen.
- Tschüss, Herr Afarsiou,
vielen Dank für Ihre Hilfe.
- Gar kein Problem.
- Das ist echt Klasse,
tschüss, Patrycja. Viel Spaß noch.
- Vielen Dank, bis morgen.
- Ich freu mich.
- Tschüss.
- Und wir fahren jetzt zu der
Frau mit der Wunde?
- Genau, die mit der infizierten Wunde,
die versorgen wir heute noch.
Genau, wichtig ist, das Bein
zwischendurch immer hochzulegen,
gerade wenn Sie irgendwie
Fernsehen gucken oder so
oder mal ein Mittagsschläfchen machen.
Genau, damit die Lymphflüssigkeit
einfach ein bisschen abfließen kann.
Fördert auch immer die Wundheilung.
Wir haben jetzt einmal die
Wundauflage draufgetan.
Vorher haben wir das schön desinfiziert,
damit wir die Bakterien und Keime einmal
reduzieren und auch abtöten können.
Die Wunde sieht ja insgesamt
deutlich besser aus.
- Geht auch schon besser.
- Genau, die Infektion ist noch sichtbar.
Wie ist das denn mit
den Schmerzen aktuell?
- Na ja, könnte besser gehen.
- Okay.
Wichtig ist immer, dass man das
Wundexsudat aufnehmen kann,
dass das einfach nicht durchsezerniert.
Das ist immer wichtig,
dass du das beachten musst.
Und auch ruhig dann auch die Patientin
fragen, ob das zu fest ist oder nicht,
weil jetzt haben wir die Möglichkeit,
dann auch noch was zu tun.
Geht das so?
- Alles super.
- Ja? Wunderbar.
Das Bein wieder ablegen.
Genau, und einmal gut festhalten, ne?
Wichtig ist dann auch wirklich, die
Mullbinde nochmal zu fixieren,
da haben wir das Fixomull für.
- Das rutscht nicht.
- Haftet auch ganz gut, genau,
weil gerade am Unterschenkel –
da die Patientin sich ja auch noch viel
bewegen möchte oder wird,
dass das nicht runterrutscht.
Und dann kannst du
hier noch mal kontrollieren:
Wenn da so ein Finger reinpasst,
dass es auch nicht zu eng ist.
Du kannst ruhig mal probieren.
Genau.
Ansonsten Verband drauflassen, nicht
drangehen und auch nicht nass machen.
- Prima. Kein Problem.
- Super, alles klar, dann war’s das.
- Super.
- Wichtig ist uns, dass jemand, der bei
uns arbeiten möchte,
eine Liebe hat zu hilfsbedürftigen Menschen,
zu pflegebedürftigen Menschen
und eine Begeisterung, im Team halt
auch zu arbeiten
und gemeinsam Dinge anzugehen.
- Empathie ... Man muss sich wirklich in die
Lage der Leute hineinversetzen können,
um sie dort abzuholen, wo sie auch stehen.
Man muss wirklich flexibel sein.
Kein Tag ist wie der andere.
Offen für neue Dinge sein
und vor allem auch bereit sein,
neue Dinge zu lernen,
weil das entwickelt sich
einfach immer weiter.
- Es gibt die Möglichkeit, ungelernt in
der Pflege zu beginnen.
Da braucht man dann einen gewissen
Zeitraum, wo man Erfahrungen sammelt,
und dann kann man sich halt auch
weiterbilden in dem Bereich.
- Die Ausbildung dauert
insgesamt drei Jahre.
Die Dinge, die man in der Ausbildung lernt,
sind einmal die Anatomie des
menschlichen Körpers,
die Krankheitsbilder sind ganz wichtig,
dann vor allem die Pflege:
Wie wäscht man Patienten,
worauf kommt es an?
Hautbeobachtungen, all solche Dinge.
Und ein wichtiger Punkt ist die
Kommunikation und die Gesprächsführung,
wie man wirklich mit den Leuten umgeht,
und sprich auch Angehörigenarbeit.
- Meistens ist mit einer
Altenpflegeausbildung
auch schon Fachabitur verbunden,
sodass man sogar nach der Ausbildung
studieren könnte.
Ansonsten gibt es so den Strang, dass
man sich zum Experten entwickelt,
was zum Beispiel
Wundmanagement angeht,
Palliativpflege oder halt in Richtung
Leitung, Pflegedienstleitung,
um dann halt auch Verantwortung
zu übernehmen
und so einen ganzen Bereich dann
zu führen.
- Das Wichtigste für mich
ist immer wirklich,
den Patienten individuell zu sehen,
so zu respektieren, wie er ist.
Wir kommen als Gast in sein Eigenheim,
holen ihn dort ab, wo er steht.
Das ist ganz, ganz wichtig
und vor allem nur Dinge zu tun,
die er auch wirklich will.
- Der Beruf macht Spaß, weil es ein Beruf
ist, wo man ganz viel zurückbekommt.
Bei jedem Patienten bekommt man
entweder ein Dankeschön
oder zumindest ein Lächeln
auf dem Gesicht,
und das gibt einem ganz viel zurück.
- Der Beruf macht Sinn.
Man weiß eigentlich, was man getan hat,
wenn man nach Hause geht.
Es erfüllt einen.
Genau, das waren immer so die Dinge,
die ich mir als Ziel gesetzt habe,
als ich den Beruf erlernt habe,
genau, die mich einfach auch
zufriedenstellen am Ende des Tages.